[Music]
what allegedly separates humans from the
so-called lower animals supposedly it's
the ability to make and use tools
however as you can see here these
chimpanzees make tools and use them to
enjoy a tasty nut meat meal
baby chimps begin experimenting at a
young age like this one that's learning
how to use a stick
female chimps demonstrate how it's done
females are markedly better at using
tools than males this fight what the
males might tell you in private it takes
ten years for a young chimp to master
the art of creating a tool and using
that tool to produce an edible foodstuff
and if you think that's complicated let
this chimpanzee ma give a lesson in the
fine art of fighting and then eating
Safari ants first mom uses a wand
selected and pruned for this delicate
task now the deal with Safari ants is
that there are rich and delicious food
source but if you don't know how to eat
them they sting like crazy now here's
what not to do try to get Safari ants
get frustrated put hand in hole and get
stung not once but twice now here's how
it's done get ants on a stick and gobble
them down Zippity quick
these aren't the only tools that chimps
have learned to use this champ uses a
bone pick to get at some tasty marrow
here a chimp uses a piece of fruit as a
sponge to get every bit of sweetness
from the Pope and this chimp
uses chewed leaves as a sponge to quench
a raging thirst are we humans actually
more advanced than chimps could you
figure out how to eat Safari ants
without getting eaten alive to have not
set
[Music]